*clapping*
Meme review
Meme Review
*clapping*
MEME REVIEW
*clapping intensifies slightly*
Welcome to another episode of Meme Review
the most beloved show on YouTube. (very funny)
YouTube put this last one on trending,
which means that I'm doing something right!! (yay)
That was a lie, *disappointment intensifies*
I don't know why I lied about that.
Let's have a quick look
from last week's Meme Review™
What were the memes we discussed?
The bike cuck meme,
which we saw some--
eeeehhh
different iterations of
which was nice to see.
Uhhh
We also have Fantano
posting:
"My content got stolen recently
-meme review stolen bike meme-
I was pretty bummed out about it,
but I think whoever stole it
was probably more happy to get it
than I'm sad to lose it,
so whatever."
What...
Is he talking about? (meme stealing intensifies)
I did not steal
Meme Review™ from anyone
Okay? (unoriginal content intensifies)
Meme
Review™
[demonic distorted voice] IS AN ORIGINAL IDEA -l-
[echo]
Now the first meme that we're gonna review [echo still going in background]
for this week's Meme Review™
is arguably
the greatest meme (yes)
of all
Time (Yas)
This is the kind of meme that sets
our civilization apart
and elevates it to another level (is that a good thing tho?)
This is humankind taking its next foot into the future
I'm talking of course
about "Petting dog" meme™.
"Petting dog™" meme must be
the greatest meme©
of all time©.
Basically you have anyone doing anything.
Oh look, I'm dog meme'ing right now
That's how easy it is
and just replace their arms
with a "petting a dog™©®".
Ho-h- How does this meme work out then?
HEH HA HA
*IEIILllle*
The thing about this meme it's that it has many layers,
it has many layers of adaptability. *layers intensify*
Almost anything can transform
in "Petting dog™" meme.
Her: he's probably thinking about other girls...
Him:
petting dog--
You even have CATS
petting DOGS.
Isn't that insane!
CORY IN THE HOUSE (the musical)
Now that's a little dank
You know?
It has a little bit of dankness to it, because clearly,
Cory is black
and the hand that's petting the dog,
is...
white.
{and severely deformed)
That is not allowed.
That is cultural appropriating.
Ah, but of course, there's some innocent ones and--
I think the flawness(?) in the meme
is what makes it funny.
Here with uh--
Josh's--
Is it Drake or Josh? I don't remember. (its josh)
Here with Josh's hand
looking completely deformed. (cyberbullying)
We have, uh, Stranger Things
with the dog meme
I'm surprised
They didn't go for
all the tentacles, ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
they--they decided to simplify the meme
to a single
tentacle
of "Petting dog™" meme.
isn't this meme just the greatest?
My personal favorite with the "Petting dog™" meme
is the fact that you can take anything that might seem as
[distorted] BAD.
You know any--any form of hand gestures
that can be seen as a negative
hand gesture,
can be saved,
through "Petting dog" meme.
Here you have me for example
uh, you have uh, Caesar
Doing the thumbs down. *cracks up at own meme*
I made this meme myself, I'm quite proud of it. *continues cracking up*
The origin of this meme
started on the "me_irl" forum,
Which I found out people aren't--
people aren't too fond of this,
the me in--irl,
but it started off with
This tweet as well
Getting a lot of attention.
I think it was first documented around November 15
So it's a--
it's a somewhat fresh meme,
some would say.
Now, this isn't really that funny, it-
*breaks out in laughter despite what he just said*
Maybe it's the skill acquired
in, eh, to pet this dog,
the way he goes out of his way to pet the dog.
That is funny about it, but, uhhhh you know,
there are some very dank
eehahahah
Options for this, of course
there's always you know other ends of each spectrum,
it's also very layered
meme of course,
there's--there's the "Petting dog" meme
"Petting dog" meme,
I'm surprised they didn't go further to be honest.
Uhhh, Then we also have
*layers intensify
I don't really...
know....
yeah, as you can see
it works for anyone it--dit--
it transcends humans.
It doesn't just have to be humans
and, uh like I said anything bad--
not that there's anything wrong with this image
--can turn into something good.
I made this one as well,
so I've seen the original... (scarred)
It also ehhhhh,
is a very compatible meme, (incoming extremely layered crossover of 6 memes)
it combines with many other memes
as you can see here
The "Petting dog™" meme really
transcends our
universal being,
it's the py--pytagaraside©, ehhhh
What was it called? Pytha---
The triangle?
[monotonous word correcter] Pythagorean Theorem
You know? How--how (incoming sciences)
philosophically the triangle--
the mathematical equation
A^2+B^2
equals C^2
is a universal
like math is universal
anywhere in the universe
A^2, B^2, C^2 (A² + B² = C²*)
is going to be the same
no matter how--
where in time
or where in universe
that is the law of the universe (felix suddenly becomes an educational channel)
we are describing something that is taking--
Transcends all of our mortal form
and just like that
this meme
does the exact same thing (!?!?!!?)
So I'm gonna have to go ahead and rate this meme
a solid...
5.5 outta ten!
all right, so we're don--
We're done with the "Petting dog™" meme
so you can go
you can go now, Edgar :(
bye!
Now...
for the next meme *excessive clapping*
please *zoom*
for meme review *ZOOM INTENSIFIES*
next! *punctual Clap*
*clap*
Monkey haircut
as we've seen here
in the...
Combin--in the cu--in the crossover meme
we have the Monkey Haircut meme
critics would say that the dog petting meme was spawned
Originally from the monkey
sad--so sorry--
the sad monkey haircut meme™
now this one is a bit older
its origin seem to be hard to pinpoint
uh, but it started with this
viral video of a cute little monkey
Getting a haircut,
but it's sad.
It's not happy about haircut.
Monkey is not too pleased about haircut
Why are you giving a monkey a haircut?!
but it was the monkey haircut that started this...
Sh- (remembers hes a Christian channel now)
bad Photoshop...
new hands sort of thing
Here we have Donald Trump.
It's actually very good match
Donald Trump giving
sad monkey haircut.
We got Rambo
giving sad monkey haircut. We have
We have, uh, Donald Trump in wrestling
giving monkey haircut.
We have monkey, giving monkey haircut
We have anime girl giving monkey haircut.
We have, of course,
the loss
Iteration of the monkey haircut
Gordon Ramsay
monkey haircut.
Big Shaq!
Stalin
monkey haircut.
And we also have the inception version of it
the monkey haircut giving monkey haircut
Uh, we also even have a pewdiepie version of it,
which I made myself (noice)
But I gotta say there's something about this meme
that just kind of annoys me...
I don't know why
It just never stops!
Here we have haircut man
Getting haircut
giving monkey haircut
the biggest crossover of memes I have ever seen              *layers intensify*
we have, of course no arms man--
Beach
person
giving monkey haircut
anime whamen haircut
Edward Sissorhands haircut
Whatever the fuck this is haircut. (post malone??)
I think what makes this meme so popular...
is because how, ehhh
shittier it looks
the funnier the meme.
here we have another one I made
and
It just becomes funny,
I would have to give this meme
a solid SIX.
It's better than the petting dog meme
because the original one is always better
Ah,
I'm gonna atatata myself there (???)
and gonna have to say
this i--I'm giving this a
4.5 ouu-
Nah, I'm gonna have--
it's a ★★★★★
It's a 5 everybody
its global
It's easily adaptable
its original.
I think it could have gotten some more points
Actually, you know what
it's a 5.2 because of its
melancholic depression undertone,
which I think will height--heighten any meme
Next!
Wooo- (incoming earape)
*earape explosion*
This is the meme
that we have all been waiting for
this is the meme that I pick
The best one for last
and not because
I need this video to be ten minutes
*clapping intensifies*
It's December, come on.
Give me that revenue,
January, is gonna be dead (woah calm down)
and I need another meme
I need a banger,
I need a banger.
What do we got?
oh?
Now that's it
That's a good meme right there.
Well done
so Xenoblade Chronicles 2, recently came out
and one of the characters...
uhh...
looks like
*ding*
truly
mind-bending
material here with the--
uh, with the back looking like... (literal
92° angle from oversized bobs)
eeuhh...
She needs a serious chiropractic visit.
Now it's not like Xenoblade has the best track record
of its
proportion...
*wheezes*
People were quick to point out, how...
Dalia, which is the name of the character,
looks like a yoshi that dre--grew a head
We immediately have people making comparison
to the-- (OH DAMN)
I think- *HUEH HA HA*
to other things looking similar
to dahlia's character design
and uhhh
From different anime combinations
that created this atrocity
Such as dick butt
Captain America perhaps (( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°))
now social justice warrior were quick to point out
how terrible this is
To objectify a whamen,
to looks like--it's something goddamn wrong with her
'if you ask' me, ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
This is perfectly fine
human anatomy
Okay?
if anything Captain America has bigger knockers than Dahlia
of course the internet was furious about this
How could--how dare they
make a disproportionate whamen in a fictional...
video game
disgusting
whenever I'm play--
now that I'm playing Xenoblade
I literally have to close my eyes.
I can't even look at it (ahhahaha)
it offends my very being
and it offends my very core
Now,
"this is not much of a meme, Felix"" you might say .
"Uhhh, what are you--what are you talking about here?"
*ponders*
*has no answer*
Thank you for watching
meme review
I'm gonna rate the last, uh
Dahlia meme
probably a solid
two and--two and a half
because, uh, it will probably be dead
in a couple days (like your monetization)
meme review
Thank you for watching another episode of
What meme do you want me to review in the next episode?
leave a comment down below
because oh boy
do I need help
We're on Episode 2 and I'm already grasping for straws
is that the expression? (nope)
I don't--
*dies*
squad fam out
meme review (clap count: 57)